[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA HARROP: Hi, I'm Jessica.
And today I'm
going to be talking
about a chemical demonstration
I like to call the steaming gun.
So you've probably seen
this before at the drugstore
or in your house.
It's called hydrogen
peroxide and it's
the stuff you put on cuts.
But it has many
other uses as well,
from bleaching things
to powering rockets,
depending on its concentration.
The solution that you get at
the drugstore is usually 3%.
So it's called hydrogen peroxide
and it's chemical formula
is H2O2.
So the atoms are
arranged like this.
It sort of looks like
water, but the extra oxygen
makes the molecule
more reactive.
Now if you leave it
alone, it decomposes
into water and oxygen. The
equation looks like this.
I'm going to balance it.
Now, normally, you
can't see this reaction
happening because at room
temperature, it's very slow.
But there are many
ways to speed it up
like increasing the temperature
or adding a catalyst.
In this demonstration
MIT's Dr. Dolhun
uses a catalyst to make
the reaction go thousands
of times faster than normal.
Let's watch.
JOHN DOLHUN: So we're going
to do this experiment here.
And basically what we've got
is we've got four bottles.
We're each going to do the
experiment in a bottle.
We've got 15 mLs of
hydrogen peroxide here.
And we're going to be
using a man-made catalyst.
We're going to be using
manganese dioxide.
And we're each going to
take a scoop of this.
And we're going to put it in.
You can set it down on the tray.
And just-- it's
starting to work.
You won't have to
stand up to see this.
You can start to see some
condensed water vapor forming
inside the flasks.
Oxygen bundles are coming out.
Now we're just going
to lightly hold that.
Whew!
JESSICA HARROP: OK,
so what happened?
Dr. Dolhun had hydrogen
peroxide in the plastic bottle.
Then he added a catalyst, some
manganese dioxide or MNO2,
and got a plume of water vapor.
So let's talk about
how a catalyst works.
I'm going to draw
a potential energy
diagram for this reaction.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So here's my potential
energy diagram.
So I've got potential
energy on the y-axis
and the reaction coordinate,
or time, on the x-axis.
The reactants are starting
at this amount of energy
and the products
have this amount.
Here, EA, that's the
activation energy.
It's the amount of energy you
need to add to the reactants
to make the reaction go.
And delta H, that's the amount
of energy that's released
when the reaction happens.
Now let's see what happens
when I add a catalyst.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With a catalyst, my activation
energy is a lot lower.
And even a small reduction
in activation energy
can make the reaction go
thousands of times faster
than it normally would.
But notice that regardless
of whether or not you
have a catalyst, the delta H,
the amount of energy released
in the reaction, doesn't change.
So the catalyst only
speeds up the reaction.
It doesn't change the
amount of energy released.
Now, take a look at this.
JOHN DOLHUN: Notice the
size of the bottles.
These are very
exothermic reactions.
The bundles have
basically shrunk down
to a very, very
tiny size compared
to the control bundles.
JESSICA HARROP:
So as you can see,
the catalyzed reaction
releases so much heat
that it actually melts the
bottles and makes them smaller.
Also, the catalyst
itself remains
unchanged by the reaction.
And designing
catalysts is actually
a key subfield of chemistry.
MIT's Richard Schrock
won the Nobel Prize
working in this field.
And remember how we
used H2O2 on our cuts?
Well, we have an enzyme
in our bodies called
catalase that does the same
thing as the manganese dioxide
that Dr. Dolhun used.
That's why when you put
hydrogen peroxide on a cut
you see fizzing and bundles.
The catalase in your
blood is breaking down
the hydrogen peroxide.
And according to recent
studies, low levels of catalase
may play a role in the
graying process of human hair.
If catalase levels are
low, it can't break down
all of the hydrogen
peroxide in the blood.
And that extra H2O2
starts to bleach your hair
from the inside out.
So to wrap up,
catalysts don't change
the products of the
reaction or how much
heat is released or absorbed.
They only change the time
it takes for the reaction
to finish.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, that's
it for me today.
I'll see you next time.